こんにちははじめ酒造です皆さんましょうーボールとか言っていますでしょうか
またばどんなに中でもちょっと it ショッピングモールとこんなカスプとが
たくさん売ってるお店があると思うんですけども
やっぱを攻めたショッピングモールとかオサレなお店にはショーウィンドウを松韻堂が
あると思うんですよね
がガスになっていてその中に例えばマネキンが服を着たりとか
万力が
起きたりとかマネーキー学校来たりとかするんですけども私は思ってしまう
僕のもの皇室を生かすとすればもう年間とあの朴正ネジそっくりなんですよ
写真ちょうどが体重とか体型とかなんかよくよく見てみると招きにそっくりだなぁと
思いまして今回の穴がいいんだけど私ちょっとゴールデンウィークで外に出たくないん
ですけどそこは勇気を振り絞ってなんだぜパパ
m ゴールデンウィークなんですけどちょっと外に行ってきますショッピングモールの
中の姉貴がたくさん並んでるおしゃれなショーウィンドウが開くわけですよ僕の机に
パルコとお店があるんですけどもあれこの章インドに並んでるマネキンたちに曲げて僕
が立ってたらバレるかバレないのかという提唱したいと思いますで僕なんか人間観察し
てて松韻堂の前を小杉湯人たちを見る
とマネキンの顔までは見てないんですよねちゃってみるとは結構いるんですけどそんな
かっツリー
デメル者いなかったので話して果たしてマネキンの中に一人
人が紛れていても気づくか気づかないか試してみたいと思いますまあ人間で肇社長山
って気づく人もいるかもしれないんでちょっとゴールで受ける人が多いんですけども目
してみたいと思いますではええええええええ
知った
始めた茶もうバレてる半分今回のポイントいかにバレーずに最初入れるかどうかですね
とがいないので今がチャンスだと思います
[音楽]
あります
やばやばや
何もこれはいん
今のところ大丈夫そうですね
[拍手]
俺いけるくれ
[音楽]
これてるのはやっぱりの日でー
女熱海まあ
m えっ
ば誰だ時はいるんだなってよね
思っているバレないんですね
[音楽]
[拍手]
舞台築けますね
ああああああ
流れ弾で炊かれたんだよね
辛い者が1人が気づくと食われる者ん
お願いいたしますなん
一時撤退しましたでも最初は意外とバレなかったですね気付かれるといっみたいなの
連鎖反応が起きて言ってにバレるっていう仕組みになっておりますちょっと離れたら
もう1回言っていこうと思います
2回じゃ行ってきます
うわぁああ晴れさあ排除催眠ガスれたんだよ
スまだ夏ようなほっともっというタイミングがあるはず
チャウン
ん
cm
[音楽]
うん
bea
[音楽]
voodoo d
ben ん
moekan
すごくでしたらすごいば舌やばいいね
ていません
あれを行けーっ
つ前バレルと人が集まりますねやっぱ気づかな人全然気づかないねぇ
今日2分以外村でぱれないああ
ボロしていていく
何してるのん
では起きたゲッチョすぐちょっと遊ぼうですよ駅ばいいなさん吉野家はから吉野やはり
この隣のステヨシネー怖いですねああ
タルク前になってるわー
もうもう近い申すツクモを作っ
うーん芽生え
いいからこれでも先に糸がたまっていると失敗するんで人が溜まってないときに
ターゲットが来るのが一番いいと思うのでちょっと待ちます
[音楽]
ブービーパルコ前集合パティんぬー試してみようと思います
いきますわぁああヌー
ん
me
あ
[音楽]
goo
音がを wh
me
はいというわけでいよいよ最終局面で質疑だ h 君がパルコの毎週落ちてくるんです
けどもう8分ねー
気づかれないと思うんですよいつ気付かあたりしようと思います
あの言って今デッキなのかマジで暑いから音ですけ
たんだよん
me
ん
[音楽]
メイズ終われないバレない
にゃんまり次第なんですよマリエ気づいている多分台地区の地図組んでちょっとほんと
周りの人しないんだよと思います頑張ってほしいです
周りの人よろしくですバレたくないとです
開いた件数
ありがとうございますじゃん
グラサンかけに行き落としますか超ちゃる
衣ちゃんのしてございます
ん
voodoo
まだモールで3も終わり使うと思う
そんなを持っているいなかった一弦ってかと考えだ
サッカーじゃなければ
どうぞちょっとわからん
[音楽]
ということでよかったしてい
浅間なあそこないですよねっ
[音楽]
me
when ん
[音楽]
me
[拍手]
[音楽]